Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to Smith from
Phenix. Smith from Phenix. Welcome to the program.
Please unmute yourself. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hello. So with Ron DeSantis seemingly
joining in the race later today officially.
And he's doing it with fanfare with Elon Musk.
I've been thinking about why Elon is wanting to
do this with the SATs and what I'm thinking. And
let me know what you think about this. Ala wants
to do this to basic. Glee incentivize Trump to
come back on to his platform and easily have a
Twitter war between DeSantis and Trump on his
platform. I'm not entirely convinced Elon is
doing this to say he's endorsing the Sanders,
but to bring him on his platform to essentially
coax Trump back on the platform when he hasn't
so far. And surprisingly, yeah.
Speaker 1: I don't think you're
wrong about that being a possible motivation for
Musk. I think there are others as well, including
that he's seeing this as a way to potentially be
a bigger player in the presidential campaign. And,
you know, there's there's personal ego reasons
and different things. But this this is something
a couple of people actually emailed me about.
SMITH which was the idea that this is going
to make. This is if Trump does nothing as far
as Twitter goes, this will make Twitter even
more of a pro DeSantis safe haven. It'll make it
overtly one. And Twitter has become very right
wing since Elon Musk took it over. You look
at the four you featured and it's just right
wing nonsense. So I think that Elon Musk may
indeed be making the calculation you're making,
which is maybe this is how you get Trump back
on Twitter. And Twitter becomes the platform
where this Republican primary plays out, which
is just great for Twitter, which quite frankly,
doesn't seem to be doing that well right now.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I have to agree with that. I do.
To me, Ellen is under the guise of free speech. So
really focusing on the Republicans. I'm not sure
how that's going to work for him in the long term.
Speaker 1: But yeah, I don't either. You know,
a lot of these business people don't like
electric vehicles and they don't like a lot of
what Elon Musk is up to and when you actually
think about it. So I don't know. You know,
politics make strange bedfellows, but let's
give it a few weeks and then we'll analyze it.
All right. Smith from Phenix. Thank
you so much for the call. Appreciate
it. Thank you very much. Let's take a very
quick break and then we'll come back and
hear from some more folks. If you're
waiting to talk to me, just hang on.